what i kind of feel bad for him
somebody's just that crying do you
recognize these voice actors from the
cuphead show
with all of them having a background in
either acting comedy writing or all of
the above it makes sense why the
anticipation for the new season has been
off the charts
number one the creators behind the show
always wanted cuphead to have an east
coast accent now let's go blow stuff up
but luckily true valentino didn't have
to study too hard he pulls from his
mom's subtle yet noticeable new jersey
accent the creators also gave him a few
old school animated movies from the
1940s to get inspiration from there are
also some mob movie vernaculars thrown
in there as well today we'll be playing
the cuphead video game as cuphead and
mugman and here we
hearts and suffer
number two
also known as mugman cuphead's slightly
more responsible
touch it what if only the devil can use
it frank tadaro has been a cuphead fan
since the video game was first released
he did play it but he wasn't very good
at it he failed many times but kept
playing it because he just loved the
visuals he wanted to see more of it
though he says the origin of mugman's
voice was a collaborative effort they
did give him references like lou
costello i got this gun i got this one i
don't got this one he spoke with game
rant about what it was like to emulate a
1930s cartoon character for me i like to
say it's as close to time travel as you
can get because you basically go back in
time and originate a character from an
older era of animation
number three luke millington drake is a
showstopper as the hilariously evil
sassy devil the sound of screaming
oh what a delicious day
a dual citizen in both the united states
and the united kingdom he decided to try
out his hand in los angeles where he
found the improv and sketch comedy
theater that he's still part of today
the groundlings theater it really was my
drama school my bachelor's kind of all
rolled into one it seems like it was
well worth whatever tuition was paid
because we couldn't imagine anyone else
playing the role of the devil
number four joe hannah plays cuphead and
mugman's father figure elder kettle they
live with their guardian slash father
figure elder kettle
one thing that stayed true to the
cuphead mythology was the fact that the
two brothers lived with him in the woods
johanna is such a seasoned voice actor
and performer with one of his first
roles in project a dating all the way
back to 1983
it makes sense that the role of elder
kettle would come naturally to him
number five king dice our favorite
charismatic game changer y'all might
know me as devil's right-hand man wayne
brady is a comedian actor and singer his
combination of skills is a big part of
the reason why he was so perfect as king
dice we knew we needed to get someone
who had huge amount of charisma they
needed someone who could host sing dance
basically do it all
wayne brady was just like he's super
funny he can actually sing like crazy
needless to say wayne brady was the
obvious choice for the role of king dice
who will be the first lucky contestant
to roll the dice
number six how could we not be excited
about this
if you've seen her as the hilarious and
brilliant nadja on what we do in the
shadows you were probably excited about
it too if me and laszlo were to have
ever had a child i like to imagine it
would look like him
she's perfectly cast as the infamous sea
monster calamaria who in the video game
is a major force to be reckoned with in
the cuphead show they balance her super
scary sea monster vibes with her
naturally hilarious show-stopping comedy
she is also known as a comedian and
screenwriter creating and co-starring in
a sketch show on bbc called ellie and
natasha with her comedy partner ellie
white
number seven not only does dave voice
the devil's dimwitted lackey henchmen
wakey
but he's also a major producer on the
show though he wouldn't describe himself
as a gamer he was a big fan of the
cuphead game because of its impact on
the animation community he didn't play
it because it was way too hard for him
but he watched the whole thing play out
on youtube when he heard there was
interest in turning it into a show he
knew he had to figure out how to get
involved number eight
also known as miss chalice
who actually makes her debut much
earlier than her originally scheduled
appearance in the cuphead dlc the
delicious last course gray is a
high-profile voice actor who has been
part of a large variety of animated
shows and video games since the early
90s her performance journey started on
some simple advice from a friend who
said that she should try comedy because
she was so naturally hilarious
so she did in her stand up routines she
did a lot of impressions which got the
attention of a casting director and the
rest was history she can literally
transform into any voice from your
childhood
[Laughter]
number nine another performer who does
it all co-executive producer cosmo
sigursson and season 2 voice of elephant
parrot and lefty has worked a whole lot
in the world of animation with content
like spongebob squarepants rocco's
modern life despicable me and camp
laszlo when it came to the cuphead show
finding the right casting crew to bring
these characters to life was hardly a
challenge for him we really looked long
and hard to find the right fits for
every physician on this project number
10 also known as the lovable short-lived
and simply unhinged bull boy he also
voiced blue from foster's home for
imaginary friends bosch von rosenberg
from final fantasy vii and reaper from
overwatch lay it on me double b
i've never done any of this crazy stuff
before
did you recognize his voice from many of
his previous works number 11 he not only
voices stickler in season two but he
also voiced sherman in season 1 episode
3 ribby and croaks he has worked on a
multitude of different projects like
doctor strange it chapters 1 and 2 and
fear the walking dead but according to
his instagram post he loved getting the
opportunity to voice the hilarious and
appropriately named character stickler
in the cuphead show
number 12
not everything is as it seems the water
being known as quadratus is found on
inkwell isle 2 and luckily requires no
bosses to be defeated in order to see
him in the video game i am quadratus the
great and wise come closer young one
cudratus simply looks like a pool of
water but when you approach him a face
that looks like an old bearded man
appears that face is voiced by gary
anthony williams williams is an actor
writer and comedian from atlanta georgia
you might recognize him from his
performance as uncle ruckus from the
boondocks bebop from teenage mutant
ninja turtles out of the shadows and
tarik jackson from harold and kumar go
to white castle
number 13. candy melo has been on tons
of animated gems some of them include
dexter's laboratory code name kids next
door astro boy foster's home for
imaginary friends and many many others
in the cuphead show she voices the
character of brandywine she grew up the
daughter of a comedian and did stand up
herself for many years when it comes to
doing voice-overs though she prefers it
to any other form of acting i can be
whatever i want to be there are no
restrictions
it's the greatest form of acting ever so
did you recognize any of these famous
voice actors from their previous work
with these actors coming from such
creative backgrounds it makes sense that
the cuphead show would be built around
this stellar cast who's your favorite
character